it's hard to overstate the impact from
software has had on gaming from birthing
its own genre to acting as the
inspiration for countless game
developers the studio's games have not
only left their mark on how games are
designed but also how players interact
with them to celebrate the release of
the studio's latest title eldon ring
here's the history of soulsborne games
[Music]
it would be remiss of me not to mention
kingsfield here even though it's not
truly classed as a soulsborne if
anything it's the first flame from which
soulsborne games were born from its
punishing difficulty and interconnected
world to souls staples like illusory
walls and deliberate precise combat it's
easy to draw a connection between king's
field and dark souls there's also the
matter of the moonlight greatsword a
weapon that appears in most of from
software's titles being in the game so
it's connected in more than a few ways i
didn't want to gloss over it completely
before we got into demon souls but for a
deeper dive into king's field and its
legacy check out this fantastic video
from our very own dave control
in 2004 29 year old hidetaka miyazaki
did the unthinkable after years working
for the american i.t company oracle he
quit and took a steep pay cut to become
a game developer at from software while
working on armoured core at the company
he heard about another project the
studio was working on a fantasy title
that wasn't exactly going smoothly with
a love of dark medieval fantasy miyazaki
asked to join the team because it was in
trouble he saw it as an opportunity to
make a game exactly how he wanted it was
already a failure in the company's eyes
so why not give it to the young upstart
no one would care if he messed it up a
bit more
wanting to steer clear of current trends
and make a quote game-like game that
took players back to basics miyazaki
changed pretty much everything about the
project upon joining the demon souls
team on the surface demon's soul sounds
like a standard action role playing game
you create your character choose a class
level up and take on a bunch of bosses
with a variety of weapons and even magic
but to describe it like that is doing it
an enormous disservice the magic of
demon souls is how it simultaneously
obtuse but also manages to explain a lot
to the player instead of teaching
mechanics through endless tutorials and
going over story via lengthy cutscenes
its lessons are delivered through trial
and error by encouraging exploration and
allowing the player to put things
together themselves the story is mostly
told through item descriptions and
cryptic conversations with npcs and as
for gameplay well
[Music]
after telling you the basics demon souls
lets you loose in the various areas of
bulletaria and up against the demons
that reside within you'll die a lot and
death has a consequence enemies you've
killed respawn your maximum health is
lowered and the souls the crucial
currency used to buy items and level up
with are lost only by making your way
back to where you died can you pick up
your remains regain your lost loot and
continue on your perilous quest if you
really wanted to you could even make it
harder or easier on yourself by
adjusting the world tendency in the game
certain actions like killing bosses
invading or defeating other players or
being killed while in body form would
affect your world tendency white world
tendency makes enemies easier to defeat
but they drop fewer rewards black
tendency is more high risk but comes
with higher rewards
demon souls was tough and from software
knew that but not everyone did the team
downplayed its difficulty in meetings
with sony fearing that the publisher
would ask them to make it easier early
reactions to demon souls were disastrous
those who went hands-on with it at tokyo
game show came away distinctly
unimpressed and shuhei yoshida then boss
of sony worldwide studios said this is
crap this is an unbelievably bad game
sony refused to publish it outside of
japan but it found a home with bandai
namco in europe and atlas in north
america while it was pretty well
received in japan sales were slow but in
the west it was a completely different
story it was critically acclaimed and
here at gamespot we even gave it our
game of the year for 2009. word of mouth
spread about this infamously difficult
but brilliant japanese game and sales
steadily rose atlas revealed that it
tripled its original sales estimate and
later sony admitted that it made a huge
mistake in refusing to publish it
worldwide demon's soul's difficulty was
key to it developing such a strong
community in-game there's a messaging
system but instead of being able to
freely write there's an enemy behind
this wall you have to pick from a list
of words and sentences to try and brute
force together a sentence that gets the
gist across while a lot of messages are
genuinely helpful offering tips and
pointing out hidden items they're also a
great way to troll others there are also
blood stains on the ground everywhere
activating them shows you the last few
seconds of another player's life in game
before they were killed people flocked
to forums and websites like gamefaqs for
help with its bosses or if they got lost
in the sprawl of boleteria and while the
game allows you to play cooperatively
with others it wasn't the easiest to
pull in a friend to help instead the
game promoted more anonymous cooperation
players could leave a summon sign on the
ground and wait for another player to
pull them into their game for help they
could emote at each other but
communication was mostly done through
action defeating bosses together
at the playstation 5 event in june 2020
it was revealed that blue point the
studio behind the shadow of the colossus
remake as well as countless other
remakes and ports would be remaking
demon souls as a playstation 5 launch
day exclusive the remake didn't change
too much from the original game graphics
were updated and playstation 5 features
like dual sense haptic feedback 3d audio
and a photo mode were added minor tweaks
were made like healing items having
weight so that you couldn't carry too
many without becoming overencumbered as
well as the addition of new weapons
armors and items bluepoint added the
fractured world a mirror mode that
flipped the level layouts as well as a
secret door that was opened by finding
26 hidden coins in the game its secret
was discovered by twitch streamer and
souls born speedrunner distortion 2 just
a week after demon souls released
so
development on a follow-up to demon
souls didn't begin immediately for
months after its release it was still
widely thought of as a failure sony held
the rights to demon souls but wasn't
interested in making another game
after the game's sales picked up in the
west bandai namco and from software
formed a partnership to create another
title dark souls the spiritual successor
to demon souls would be the game that
catapulted from software into the
spotlight
the age of fire is coming to an end you
play as the chosen undead and awaken in
a land called lordran at the end of the
age of fire humanity has been cursed by
the dark sign and those afflicted cannot
die instead resurrecting over and over
until they go mad also known as
hollowing you're tasked with collecting
four lord souls to either relink the
first flame to extend the age of fire or
let it die so the world falls into the
age of dark like demon souls the story
isn't really explicitly told or
over-explained beyond the opening cut
scene inspiring players to come together
to discuss the law implications of
lordran and its inhabitants from the
hollowed and the demons to the god-like
creatures that once roamed the land but
unlike demon souls which has arch stones
in a hub world that would transport the
player to different locations the dark
souls map is a huge intricately
connected one after landing at firelink
shrine the safe hub of the game players
are free to explore the world unlock
shortcuts and create checkpoints for
themselves by finding and lighting the
bonfires they come across
walking around lordran is an incredible
feeling from all over you can see other
areas that you'll likely shortly
encounter when you unlock shortcuts the
world just makes sense that it exists
and that you're slowly uncovering its
secrets in the beginning you have one
simple objective ring the two bells of
awakening the path to getting there is
up to you to uncover but it won't be
easy dangerous bosses devious traps and
lots of dying lie in your way while you
can summon npcs to aid you in boss
fights cooperative play with other
humans was not only possible but in some
cases encouraged dark souls introduced
the covenant system to the series where
players pledge to various factions and
are rewarded by following the covenant's
rules typically in online play the
warriors of sunlight for example is a
covenant that promotes a bit of jolly
cooperation between players and rewards
new miracles as you advance through its
ranks
dark souls was an immediate success when
it launched for playstation 3 and xbox
360 outselling demon souls almost
immediately strong sales guaranteed the
release of the artorias of the abyss
expansion and fans lobbied for the game
to come to pc from software was not very
familiar with developing games for pc
however and had issues with the pc port
famously the game's resolution was
locked at 1024x720
a neogaf user named durante fixed the
issue by releasing a mod called dsfix
which fixed the resolution and upped the
frame rate to 60 frames per second
while demon souls paved the way dark
souls was from software's breakout hit
despite launching alongside titans like
skyrim batman arkham city and portal 2
it stood out from the other games of
2011 because it was simply unlike
anything else demon souls despite
over-performing its estimates and being
a beloved game was still relatively
niche and locked to playstation 3. dark
souls was multi-platform and it was most
people's first souls game or it was at
least the first time they'd heard of the
franchise it was blisteringly difficult
but the feeling of victory washed away
all of the pain that you went through
its world was bleak but shimmers of hope
shone through and communities came
together to unlock its every secret
numerous games have tried to aid what
dark souls did for gaming with varying
levels of success and its name is still
revered to this day often cited as one
of the best games ever made
dark souls 2 would be the first souls
game not to be directed by hidetaka
miyazaki miyazaki had his hands full
working on bloodborne but supervised
dark souls 2 handing the reigns over to
tomohiro shibuya and yui tanimura
development was not easy with tanimura
explaining in the game's design works
book that midway through development he
took over as sole director and that the
team had to rethink the entire game
changing roles for certain characters
and fitting new locations into the map
naturally dark souls 2 shares a lot of
similarities with dark souls but
differed in a few key ways drangleic was
less interconnected and less interesting
than lordran and the game's map was a
little more linear it was also made in a
new engine which improved its graphics
although that was debatable to some fans
and audio tweaks had been made to combat
backstabs and parries were a little
tougher to land and some enemies would
stop respawning after you killed them a
certain number of times to discourage
players from farming souls and over
levelling dark souls 2 also has way more
bosses over 30 to dark souls 22 but a
common complaint was that too many of
them were just big lads in armor the
game experimented with elements of demon
souls with players max health being
reduced if they died unless they found
the ring of binding which would limit
just how much it would reduce but once
again the game received universal
critical acclaim and a trilogy of dlc
called the lost crowns was soon released
an updated version of the game was
released for ps4 xbox one and pc and
came bundled with the dlc it was called
dark souls 2 scholar of the first sin
its visuals were updated enemies were
moved around so the game acted almost
like a remix of the vanilla game and it
was playable at 60 frames per second but
this version of the game came with a bug
that had plagued pc players of the base
game your weapon would degrade faster at
higher frame rates because for some
reason the degradation stat was tied to
the game's frame rate this wouldn't
actually be fixed for over a year over
time fan sentiment towards dark souls 2
has definitely waned although there's a
great video essay by h bomber guy who
argues that it's actually secretly
really really good i really recommend
you watch it
while not strictly a souls title
bloodborne shares a lot of its dna with
the franchise and is often thrown in
with the rest hence the catch-all name
soulsbornes development on the project
began sometime in 2012 under the name
project beast sony still kicking
themselves about dropping demon souls
came to from software to ask to
collaborate on another game for the
upcoming playstation 4 console set in
the decrepit rotting city of yharnam on
the night of the hunt where hunters
purge the beasts that roam its streets
the only problem is these beasts were
once residents and it's up to you to try
and find answers to the plague that's
overtaken the city and escape the
nightmare you found yourself in
bloodborne shun to the fantasy setting
of demons and dark souls and instead
leans into gothic horror and the terror
of lovecraftian cosmic beings a new stat
called insight unlocks your mind to the
true horrors of yharnam and as you
progress through the game these cosmic
beings or great ones become visible to
you bloodborne is very similar to the
souls games in a number of ways but when
it comes to combat it's a completely
different
beast
while souls promotes a more measured
cautious approach blocking and waiting
for openings from behind a shield
bloodborne encourages aggression when
you're hit by an enemy a short window
opens where doing damage to the person
that hit you gives you back health
pushing the player to attack rather than
cower and regroup your weapons now
transform and stacking combos together
feels fluid and powerful shields were
removed from the game well save one
wooden shield that calls you a coward
for picking it replacing it in your left
hand is a gun when fired at just the
right time it stuns the enemy and opens
them up for a visceral attack which
deals extra damage bloodborne was and
this may surprise you critically
acclaimed upon release and was quickly
referred to as the best playstation 4
exclusive game and a true killer app for
the console it was added to playstation
now and later to the playstation plus
collection on playstation 5 but still
nothing about a pc release a few months
after it came out it received a meaty
dlc expansion called the old hunters
which takes players back in time and up
against a whole host of new bosses
as with other souls games bloodborne's
difficulty was key to helping its
community grow not only were people
coming together to learn how to beat the
game normally it has a strong speed
running community with players figuring
out how to beat it in the fastest time
and even doing runs without taking any
hits bloodborne's cut content also
intrigued folks to come together to mine
every last secret they could from the
game its first trailer showed a lot of
mechanics and weapons that didn't
actually make it into the final product
and players have combed through its code
to uncover cut bosses locations and bits
of story it's been seven years since
bloodborne was released and people are
still finding things
dark souls 3 was to be a culmination of
everything from software had learned
while creating its other games directed
by miyazaki but co-directed by dark
souls 2's yuui tanimura and isamu okano
who had previously directed steel
battalion heavy armor and was a game
designer on bloodborne dark souls 3 was
to straddle the line of being both
familiar but pushed new ground for the
studio
speaking at e3 2015 miyazaki said that
dark souls 3 wouldn't be the final
product for the dark souls franchise but
instead act as a turning point for the
series and for from software as a whole
its story follows similar beats and
themes of the previous games and its
combat while very familiar to those who
had played previous souls games is a
little faster and dynamic archery was
much improved with miyazaki revealing
that the team at from was inspired by
legolas from lord of the rings the game
introduces a new stat luck and weapon
arts special skills that can give you
the edge in a fight like breaking an
enemy's guard or dealing more damage
dark souls 3 aimed to encourage a
greater sense of exploration its map was
bigger but also fairly interconnected in
a way that fans had loved in dark souls
and bloodborne despite some technical
issues and a rough frame rate at launch
it was very well received by fans and
critics who emboldened by their
experience with bloodborne and its
aggressive combat praised the faster
fights in dark souls 3 as well as the
gorgeous world of lothric some
complained that the game didn't feel as
fresh or exciting as previous titles
lacking surprise and relying too heavily
on series mainstays regardless it was
the fastest selling game in bandai
namco's history and two pieces of dlc
the ringed city and ashes of ariandel
were released dark souls 3 might not
have moved the needle as much as some
souls fans hoped but from software's
next game sakura shadows died twice
would be a vast departure for the studio
an action-adventure game more in line
with tenchu than dark souls
as it's not a soulsborne i'll not dwell
on it too much but it's really fun to
chart the changes the studio made to its
games as their approach to game design
evolved over time
which brings us to eldon ring which
looks to be a culmination and evolution
of these soulsborne games so far taking
the core tenets of dark souls and
setting players loose in an expansive
open world and letting them make their
own path a song of ice and fire author
george r.r martin contributed to the
game's law with miyazaki taking up the
reigns as director once again
new is the ability to ride a mount a
spectral steed named torrent as well as
crafting using materials you've gathered
from enemies and the environment the
lands between it looks to be huge and
players need to collect map shards to
unfog the map to explore not only can
you play cooperatively with people
online but in certain areas you can
summon spirit ashes spectral beings that
attack enemies for you borrowing from
sakura you can stealth through various
areas and even jump offering more ways
to dispatch enemies elden ring has been
delayed a couple of times but is finally
launching in 2022 and i can't wait
so there you have it the history of
soulsborne games for more from software
make sure to keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot and be sure to let me know
which one is your favorite in the
comments below you can find me on
twitter i'm at lucy james games and
thanks for watching